located in the granite heart of
California's mighty Sierra Nevada
mountain range Yosemite is one of the
United States first wilderness parks
it's visited by three and a half million
people each year
Yosemite National Park is home to North
America's highest waterfall Yosemite
Falls a nearly two-and-a-half thousand
foot drop makes this an iconic image of
the park some of the visitors look for
adventure and may climb Half Dome a
Granite Peak more than 4,800 feet high
although a long and challenging hike a
climb here requires no special expertise
more experienced climbers aim for El
Capitan
a 3,000 foot peak it is the largest
monolith of granite in the world
yosemite 'he's great granite peaks were
once the fiery heart of an immense
volcano 100 million years ago massive
bubbles of magma rose into a huge
chamber five miles beneath the surface
of the earth that magma cooled into a
single gigantic slab of granite 350
miles long 60 miles wide and 10 miles
thick as water eroded the overlying rock
the granite rose we see parts of it
today as El Capitan and yosemite x'
other great stone sentinels and yosemite
boasts other iconic images much younger
than the granite but very old when
compared to other living things on earth
giant sequoias reach 300 feet up as high
as a twenty seven storey building some
sequoias have been around for up to
three thousand years scientists here are
climbing the Giants to study how well
the trees pump water from the ground and
how climate change could be affecting
them
Yosemite providing a glimpse at Earth's
ancient past and offering a window to
its constant changes